it's time to fight hi this is senior
editor Kevin van ORD standing in for
reviewer Miguel concepción to tell you
about Hyrule warriors
you might be prepared to trash Hyrule
warriors a dynasty Warriors meets Legend
of Zelda mashup no one ever asked for
but once you open that first chest and
Link thrusts that treasure toward the
camera you realize that this is a Legend
of Zelda spin-off worth taking seriously
and you're reminded that sometimes it's
these left-field concepts that make the
most sense the majority of the Warriors
games are basic exercises and tactical
map management that also let you become
the main contributor to the action at
ground level it's there that you slice
your sword through throngs of simple
foes which proves simultaneously
unimaginative and empowering as you
liberate one fortification from enemy
hands
another keep is being invaded the key to
winning often comes down to simply being
faster than your enemy and filling in
the map with your color-coded forces
like the one piece pirate warriors
crossover series Hyrule warriors is more
focused on objectives and less on
removing opposition forces from the map
if you wish you can try to make the game
feel more like a traditional Warriors
game by taking over each fort one at a
time that creates its own challenges
since many of the objectives and Hyrule
warriors have times deadlines but Hyrule
warriors is at its most stimulating when
it tests your management of priorities
as a Zelda fan of course you want to
save the Deku Tree when it's being
invaded on all sides but you're also
close to liberating a keep on one of the
far corners of the map and since you've
just reached a thousand kills a
collectible object has temporarily
appeared on the map make a choice
warrior waffling is for the weak
setting priorities isn't as easy as it
sounds the biggest rush comes when
you've completed all the mid mission
objectives and you're left
racing against the enemy toward the
victory and defeat conditions even if
you confront the boss with a full bar of
Health the same can't be said about the
health of your home base at the other
end of the map should you return to your
base or stay and try to defeat the boss
to end the mission not knowing your HQ s
health unless you're actually inside
your HQ helps add mystery and suspense
to your tactical decisions for all the
Legend of Zelda related items jingles
and familiar faces that are thrown at
you every other second Hyrule warriors
still sticks closely to the typical
dynasty Warriors structure if you have
dynasty Warriors muscle memory then you
know that the first thing to do at the
start of the first mission is to jump
into the fray get to work in liberating
the nearest fort and set yourself on a
path to at least a thousand kills and as
a Warriors game in 2014 Hyrule warriors
reaps the benefits from many of the
lessons and criticisms leveled at prior
games most notably the boss lock-on
option that was introduced a few years
ago
the greatest trick Hyrule warriors pulls
is in convincing Zelda fans that the
game might just belong in the
much-debated Legend of Zelda timeline
further validating this idea is that the
story mode is supported by
interdimensional journeys to various
Legend of Zelda worlds as an argument
for and against the notion of canon
eligibility Hyrule warriors even manages
to rehash key plot points from the
franchise that are also significant
spoilers to the very very few who will
play this game but have never beaten a
Legend of Zelda game every character in
Hyrule warriors modest playable roster
possesses unique attacks and animations
watching link perform spectacular melee
attacks only makes one wish such potent
moves were available in mainline Legend
of Zelda games you may notice however
that Hyrule warriors does not avoid
previous Warriors games archetypes you
can see Omega forces signature
familiarity with wushu martial arts in
some of em posit acts you Connor Lana
with her adorned sleeves exposed midriff
and giant ponytail would not look out of
place in a Dynasty Warriors game
characters aside Hyrule warriors adds
little to the Warriors mega series as a
whole but as one of the more well
produced Warriors game in recent memory
it's easy to see Hyrule warriors opening
the series up to even more spin-offs if
the Warriors franchise has proven
anything it's that almost every
entertainment property is fair game and
that is both exciting and scary
you